l'épisode de cette semaine est encore
une fois présenté par nos bons amis chez
police l'ip d'homs et car la dernière
fois que je change de tomates lui ça
fait tellement longtemps que je m'en
souviens pas ça ça veut dire que ça fait
trop longtemps je vous fais en doute
si vous expérimentez des courbatures ou
matin que ce soit dans le coup dans le
dos si vous avez de la difficulté aussi
à dormir à deux c'est parce que thomas
triffen genre de film qu à huy lozada
mène vers l'autre personne à voir texte
sa faim jarre de vortex au centre doit
être un droit mais ça ça veut dire qu'
il est temps changer votre matelas moche
et que dernièrement j'ai changé mon
matelas en fait puis ça fait toute la
différence
les matelas de police libre offre trois
types de matelas en fait qu'ils sont
adaptés à tous les budgets et à tous les
besoins vous en parlait déjà dans
d'autres podcast tout un oreiller pour
l'esprit pour ceux ne riez pas les
cibles de la dore puy je devrai
certainement investir dans un matelot
police l'ip pourquoi parce que je dors à
toutes les nuits à toutes les nuits
georges utilise un matelas c'est
beaucoup d'heures dans ma vie ces gens
le tiers de ma vie je passe sur mon
match
donc pourquoi pas avoir le meilleur
match possible tout à fait tout à fait
leur oreiller badauds et sont tus peu
les costauds mazet selon tes besoins day
arrive d'une certaine façon on peut les
enlever shaked ont modifié un petit peu
on aurait il y en a qui aiment ça et pme
qui monsieur ben mince ses préférences
chacun de ses préférences tous leurs
matelas ont évidemment la mousse anti
microbiennes qu'on vous a déjà parlé qui
s'assure que vous ayez pas d'acariens
puis de microbes s'accumulent dans vos
matelas on a un code promo pour vous
autres qui le n100 filtre s25 pour 25 %
de rabais sur tous exceptés les sommiers
pis cette offre là pardon est valide
jusqu'au 7 décembre et on était en nette
baisse en août à noël temps parfait pour
s'offrir un petit cadeau police les
oyats baby
aujourd'hui le podcast est commandité
par jus frais ph par mois du frère
jus frais c'est une compagnie québécoise
qui vous offre les jeux les plus frais
cela c'est pas la première fois qu'on en
parle mais c'est parce que c'est comme
ça qu'on les aime jus frais ils font vos
juges la veille ils voulaient livre le
lendemain si vous êtes dans les environs
de montréal c'est un flop près de 3
pièces pour livraison le lendemain donc
pas plus frais que si vous êtes à
l'extérieur de montréal c'est le prix
deux postes canada puis c'est expédié
évidemment la journée même donc vous
pouvez pas avoir des jeux plus frais que
moi je tombe en amour littéralement avec
jus frais pile là pour descendre ni ont
lancé un nouveau jus qu'on tient devant
nous ici c'est nous regarder en vidéo
c'est un jeu aux canneberges à la menthe
et à la lime donc un jus du temps des
fêtes puis d'homme vas-y moi j'ai déjà
goûté j'ai tripé donne un intéressant
mélange de savoir gérard devaux -
qu'est-ce que ça goûte sur eux
le palais aux magog sa vie active ne met
pas vrai ça a été bon jus pour vrai pied
mais c'est vrai c'est vraiment j'ai
jamais cessé c'est une nouvelle
sensation pour moi c'est jules c'est
délicieux ouais ça fait vraiment temps
des fêtes en fait vous allez pouvoir des
jeunes et ce dans votre brunch au
lendemain de noël en ouvrant vos cadeaux
possiblement de seulement votre
appartement parce que noël est pas mal
quand c'est laid mais ça c'est un autre
sujet si vous aller commander sur jus
frais point c'est un triple double 20
points jugent très pointilleux utilise
le code promo s f10 pour 10% de rabais
sur tout votre commande
merci la gamme de jus frais on vous
recommande grandement de les encourager
parce que
une gang des faits la pauvre et c'est
très bon vraiment bon ouais tu vis une
production du studio sf bio sans filtre
les podcasts on parle de ce qu'on veut
que nos invités date cette super quentin
avec moi baby de pointe avec moi de me
plante le cette semaine dans le fond on
vous demande
on vous demande on vous implore d'aller
voir nos pages piquionne parce que c'est
là que ça se passe pour vrai après
chaque podcasts ont fait encore moins de
filtrer ce qu'on discute de la
conversation avec nicole ou est-ce qu'on
des bruits il faut un petit peu du
podcast convient d'avoir 100% exclusif à
béthune puis on a aussi on veut sûrement
a enregistré éventuellement le l'optique
qui et quand vous écoutez c'est déjà en
ligne un podcast vip ou est-ce que de
mémoire répond à des questions qui ont
été posées par nos membres et qu elle
veut aller voir sur le lien va être dans
la descente du pas de casque sinon cette
semaine d'hommes
cette semaine toujours un grand plaisir
de recevoir notre bon ami nicolas
ouellette c'est sa deuxième faux pas de
castille venu jouer bach qui dans les
premiers le je pense qu'ils étaient
français accordent en m'accusant cuisine
à ph leveleux plus de deux ans et c'est
son grand retour dit vous revenez ben
c'est là que ça se passe
la prophétie série on a parlé de la fal
en fait le premier sujet qu'on est quand
même très directe de danse et là la
petite controverse ben c'est la grosse
controverse que au québec et au canada
autour de l'utilisation du mot à n en a
parlé dans les médias ne parlent et non
pas là du monde en parle
puis on avait parlé de ceux avec nicolas
dans le tableau 2 on a eu cette
conversation le du fait que je n'utilise
pas un moule
ben c'est simple on est revenu sur le
sujet sûr qu'ils existent toute cette
polémique lors qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensaient qu'est ce qu'on en pense et se
séparent intéressant on a parlé de
deux plaintes à faire le jeu c'est
incroyable on a parlé aussi comment
créer un changement dans le monde en
fait par où ça passe puis les
générations qui s'en viennent dans le
fond comment nicolas était optimiste par
rapport à ce qui s'en venait pour le
futur puis on s'est posé la question
est-ce que les gens qui nous ont
précédés était aussi optimiste envers
nous que on peut l'être envers les plus
jeunes le nous on parle de ça encore une
fois on traînait un petit peu notre âge
parce qu'on se fait plus si jeune que ça
m'ait vraiment une belle personne qui
est un grand communicateur c'est
vraiment toujours un plaisir de discuter
avec lui yes fait que écouter sans plus
attendre on voulait sur le podcast
commenter ce que vous pensez la
conversation puis par les à vos amis
fait que mon podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
dec j'ai condamné d'albert venir vous
voir
on n'a pas de chien ça change et ça a
changé l'aspect de l'appartement où
j'étais la dernière fois mais la
conversation avec extra nostalgie et le
son sont en phase avec votre énergie
ça fait deux ans d'études en nous et
c'était au tout début
ouais et on était des jeunes deux ans
plus tard maintenant que vous avez un
empire médiatique pour rivaliser qui
plus est devenu ici un mois je suis
revenu je suis venu peu tard que cet été
avec j'ai fait une très longue
conversation synphot les gens de presque
trois heures c'est jeff et des longues
conversations me dit bon pour faire des
longues conversations
il y est bon pour est juste ouvrir
pendant vraiment contente d'un grand
comme pas compte c'est de la vraie
curiosité
ce qui est intéressant et je pense que
n'importe qui qui vient mais que ce soit
à votre podcast ou broadcast geass les
choses ont donc fait le plus parler ou
presque oui parce qu'il ya quelque chose
dans gages
c'est dans cette conversation le des
choses qu'on dit par ailleurs par manque
de temps lucidement les gens soit des
cours souhaite entendre parler de
quelque chose autrement souhaite
entendre pour la première fois aller au
bout d'une idée que déjà exprimé de
façon plus concise ailleurs
puis on dirait que ça fait aussi que ça
ça fait que les gens ont plus tendance à
vouloir witch et puis moi ça me fait
bien plaisir dans le pouvoir c'est
continuer à entretenir cette
conversation là à l'extérieur du balados
a donné des mieux ah tu vois piégeux
je voulais pas qu'on parle de ça surtout
pas aussi rapidement mettait tant
passage monsieur libre pieds tu sais
comme un peu à leur phase avec un débat
d'actualité mais si on avait parlé du
jeu peut s'enseigner du mot à la haine
qu'ils ont avec l'exemple des quels
objectifs on ne peut plus des brûlures
une discussion dans ce métier c'est une
des fois je me suis alors souvent
beaucoup de messages d'opinion par
rapport à ce grand espace de réflexion
puis c'est comme si on avait touché à
l'horizon s'est ressenti de woippy la
ccxr sortie dans les médias de masse est
sûr que c'est des débats qui sont
sensibles qui sont épidermiques pour les
jambes je pense que n'importe quel sujet
le qu'on parle du moins n importe quel
sujet qui qui qui fait que les gens
disent les gens se sentent brimés en
quelque sorte de pouvoir exprimer ou
s'exprimer de la façon la plus libre de
la façon dont ils le souhaitent
c'est sûr que ça crée de l'irritation
mais je pense que là on est dans une ère
où quand on est dans une position de
privilèges faut apprendre à faire des
concessions pour une grosse concession
la martinoire dire le vrai nom est grand
plus grosse sinon métier on avait reçu
ce tableau juste bon vérité c'était du
monde mais celles imaginées ont vraiment
ça a été aussi quelque chose au-delà
d'un point de vue plus personnel la
conversation qu'on a vu le deux ans
autour de ce salon a été une des
conditions que le plus raisonnée
maintenant longtemps à moi parce que
c'est quelque chose qui c'est une des
fois où un skieur ou sql j'ai reçu une
information qui à ce moment là mais je
m'étais même pas encore apparu très sens
que ça venait d'arriver là faire avec
kendrick
évidemment je suis pour le moment rien
d'am-dam un dans ma vie ne sait jamais
sauf que là de farah qui n'ont pas peur
vous savez très catégorique
puis dis ça mais je reste et je
l'utilisé
non mais pour moi c est encore à ce jour
ces sites on est heureux et c'est encore
mon opinion à 100%
si après ça je pense que toutes les
nuances qu'on peut apporter selon les
contextes mais le problème je pense
actuellement puis j'ai hâte que ce soit
pris comme ça c'est que quand une
personne racisées face à un débat de ce
genre le tapage fait un put de camper et
moins 10 à 20% de façon plus radicale
que ce que tu pourrais l'être si la
société était en mode acceptation et
compréhension complète de 6 ans je suis
souvent moi je commençais à avoir des
conversations tu es dans le privé d'une
certaine façon avec ma blonde avec mes
amis sur le sujet on est capable d'avoir
d'apporter des nuances plus haut mais
c'est clair que dans le public je veux
pas le laisser la chance aux gens
laissent la porte ouverte exact
d'interpréter de façon différente que ce
qui est vraiment mon intention ce que
j'ai à dire
puis dans les faits en ce moment dans
l'utilisation du mot t'utilises bosmont
le site est pas noir pour étouffer
c'est terminé tant pis si tu es noir
après sa main tu décides selon les
sensibilités des gens qui sont avec toi
mais je pense que c'est important de
respecter ses sensibilités
d'après ce canton soit rendue ailleurs
le sait exactement la loi
commençons par le commencement c'est
vrai que c'est drôle moi aussi comme ph
6 marchena a à dire métive le 2 ans tu
es comme le début de la réflexion autour
de 6 pi non plus je ne citerai pas dans
ma vie courante
sauf que ty d'être blanc venant de
sainte foy
originaire de sainte foy puisque des
questions que je me pose arrive dans un
milieu où je suis forcé j'ai été forcé
de me poser ces questions-là puis moi je
le dis tout le temps comme les cévennes
et six autres choses de process aussi
dispo vrai que jours en août entend
parler d'un enjeu il faut que tu le
comprennent à 100% que ton pote procès
soit rendue à l'endroit où il doit être
pour par exemple que tu acceptes qu'il
ya une introspection à vivre parce que
justement ya un chemin à parcourir pour
que tu reconnais ce qui est ce chemin à
parcourir mais ce qui me gausse si
souvent les gens qui dès qu'ils vont
entendre parler d'un enjeu vont se
camper dans une position qui vont plus
pouvoir être ouvert à la discussion à
partir de ce moment le seul c'est
problématique pour moi mais le fait
qu'ils ont ce 10è mois en 2016 je
pensais comme ce puits aujourd'hui en
2020 2021 je pense comme si puis un
chemin 588 1 266 que j'ai fait parce que
je pense
que tu as fait un bon ça me dérange pas
il n'y a pas de problème l'iphone on est
des humains on évolue notre pensée
change notre pensée donc ça va dans la
bonne direction
je pense qu'il faut accepter ce que ça
te facilite d'être forcés que j'imagine
que ces conversations le tulle souvent
est ce que c'est ce que sa part été
forcé la voit pratiquement pas ce que
les gens doivent parler ses lunettes
kanak avant c'est pour parler de ça mais
ça ça tirait dessus d'être comme traînée
dans un débat qui prétend que des fois
septembre même pas de participer à moi
je comprends que certaines personnes
militantes racisées soit irrité parce
qu'ils portent ces conversations là
depuis très longtemps dans leur vie puis
ont l'impression que c'est un combat qui
ont commencé au jour 02 leur vie jusqu'à
alors jouissons rendu on va la faire
c'est qu'il ya eu un long moment de ma
vie où c'était pas des enjeux sur
lesquels je me positionner ou même
auquel je réfléchissais dit il dit j'ai
une sainte foy je le dis souvent j'ai
grandi là seule personne noire dans ma
vie pendant un long moment
ça a été mon frère une coupe de gars
avec qui jouent aux sequins tactis ma
réflexion autour de 6 ans jeux ea s'est
amorcé plus à l'âge adulte
à ce jour non je peux encore tanner d'en
parler 1 parce que je comprend d'où les
gens viennent quand ils disent qu'ils
ont pas encore réfléchi à ces enjeux le
parce que j'étais cette personne à
certains moments puis deux parce que je
pense que c'est important qu'on ait des
traits d'union qui est des gens
justement qui prennent le relais de la
conversation puis du pis tu combats puis
de la nuance puis je suis pas trop
techno je suis pas je protège pas encore
réalité on va se parler
pour l'instant non non je peux tu année
il ya quelque chose d'ailleurs à tout le
monde en parle qui a dressé le sujet un
peu puis au final une fois au dessus du
beau jeu jusqu à sa plus simple
expression le si quelqu'un dit cadre du
10e je me sens pas bien il respecte
c'est assez c'est assez
at-on le puits après ça je fais un petit
flashback quant à tout le monde en parle
encore il y avait traité du sujet il y
avait invité webster entre autres le
flot de deux semaines les trois quarts
de la mort et mille et une couleurs
vives et sa destinée et puis ça commence
en disant moins ça me fait de la peine
rentré ça me fait de la peine quand vous
dites quand j'entends ce moulin puis
après seule espèce de deux joutes
verbales ou est-ce que guillaume il
décide de le dire que demain on dirait
le plus souvent possible en nommant tout
les livres qui ont le mot haine dans le
titre sur le plateau alors qu'il vient
juste de dire un mot quand j'entends sur
ça je me sens demain avec moi j'ai
l'impression que quand tu tues boys band
ce débat là sa plus simple expression le
sait alors ce régime c'est ça aussi dans
n'importe quelles situations
contentieuses dans laquelle tu vas te
retrouver été franches et en dévot l'api
moitié voici ma blonde qui me disent on
m'en donne et puis ça m'a vraiment fait
réfléchir je sais pas trop est bien vu
un enjeu une chicane en deux amis machin
pis il y en a un qui dit à l'autre
et peu importe que tu as voulu dire la
façon dont tu le dis ça m'a blessé
descoings portiste ont l'intention
n'était pas de me blesser la résultante
est que je suis blessé
ma blonde avait dit la première chose à
faire quand la personne qui est celle
qui a blessé l'autre c'est juste de
faire est pauvre et je m'excuse je suis
désolé je veux faire attention la
prochaine fois si tu veux qu'on s'en
reparle
on s'en reparlera pionce explique ross
qui s'est passé je te donnerai mon point
de vue il le fait de dire juste et je
m'excuse
on en parlera quand il sera prêt souvent
ça va créer l'ouverture ça va faire que
la personne va faire ok tu es auront la
conversation ayant un dialogue mais peut
pas y avoir des dealers et des dialogues
quand la personne
en position de blessés ou en position de
privilèges pitt fait non mais tu
comprends pas ce que tu vis et pas
valide moi par exemple ce que tu vis je
le comprends mais je vais t'expliquer
pourquoi tu le vis puis comment tu
devrais le vivent
le dialogue n'a personne à ma juste se
tourner les oreilles des enfants pauvres
ça devrait porter ses pas l'autre patois
de santé les témoins d'une émotion ses
mots c'est moi qui la vie et tu valides
ou et pas valide
je le sais pas mais le jeu la vie et mon
émotion est réelle malgré tout ironique
mais dans tout ce débat là on n'a jamais
autant la facture mais c'est sous tipis
clairement figure partait justement avec
la loi qu'on a nommé mais avec les
rendements dans le cas de citer une
oeuvre ou dans un contexte académique
ceux ci combien les gens de deux amants
mal je pense que certaines personnes
viennent apporter à cette règle bon moi
j'aurai plein de choses à dire là-dessus
mais je trouve qu'on sait pas encore
entendu soirée fait que le mot que
l'utilisation du mot peu importe elle
est dérogatoire puis elles ont un poids
qu'une charge pour les gens qui font
partie de ces communautés le manger ces
conversations mais aussi avec des
collègues au travail tient du canada
entre autres où se dit tisci dommages
parfois plus que ce soit radio canada ou
dans n'importe quel média traditionnel
c'est que j'ai l'impression que on parle
pas de la basse et on n'a pas le
discours du départ qui dirait on
comprend ce que veut dire ce moulin dans
un contexte historique
on ne comprend que l'utilisation est
blessante pour une certaine partie de la
communauté des gens qui nous suivent des
gens qui nous écoutent des gens qui nous
regardent ça c'est notre posture on
pense que ce moule n'est pas un nom un
mot adéquat après ça on prend la
décision d'avoir une conversation plus
poussées sur ce sujet là parce qu'on
pense que ça donne je suis pour le notre
rôle de diffuseur public ou pas ou
généraliste ou pas d'abord ces
conversations le mais je trouve que
c'est rare qu'on a eu au départ une
admission que
et de ce qu'on interprète de d'une
situation justement le ticket
dérogatoires qui peut être douloureuse
comme pour une personne comme moi je
pense que c'est important quand même si
je sais que toute l'éthique des médias
je sais que tout l'idée de la de
l'objectivité petit saut mais je pense
que juste que d'admettre qu'un mot
puisse blesser et avoir une charge
puisse prendre position par rapport à
cette charge le piia small eur puis à
certains contextes on refuse que son
utilisation soit fils je pense que ça
pourrait être bon ben ça pourrait porter
bien encore une fois c'est comme ça tu
commences les conversations ouais
peut-il encore du monde qu'ils utilisent
justement au premier niveau d'ensemble
d'utiliser de façon dérogatoire de façon
péjorative
aujourd'hui donc c'est seul problème
auquel il faut s'attarder
ces moyens là aussi le problème je pense
quand on s'est éclaté puis à gonfler des
conversations autour d'une situation
comme celle là autour du moins n
c'est la personne qui est pas
nécessairement dans un contexte où elle
peut avoir ces conversations leur
direction de 2e 3e niveau pee qui entend
une bribe de conversation qui est non
mais on peut l'utiliser le moindre pli
c'est ce qu'a décidé de retenir dans sa
fille elle entendu du bruit dans toute
la conversation
l'information n'est bon là pour
sélectionner l'information qui nous
valide dans ce qu'on pense ou dans ce
qu'on veut dire ou dans la façon dont on
veut s'exprimer avec moi c'est sûrement
greg
tout ça pour dire le tir résumons pour
moi résumé ce grand déballage
c'est simple ils l'utilisent post moulin
gros gros sacrifices dans la mine exact
très justement à guillot qui emploie le
mot le tpiy j'étais ricardo lamour qui
était justement au lui même terreau
porter plainte
c'est parce que simon jodoin les
répétitions de l'émission à radio-canada
donc pile tipi le guillou fait
précisément ce type il a vraiment qu'ils
voulaient
l'amant de médication crédit poser c'est
si je cite si si on parle du neuf et
j'ai dit son titre est ce que ça vous
heures c'est la question qui a été posée
en fait il le sait me poser si je ne
m'abuse à webster et webster comme un
peu dit oui oui nantis dans un contexte
est plus je peux je peux le mal le site
et paraphraser de façon de mauvaise
façon là mais j'ai l'impression que lui
ce qu'ils disent eh oui le peut-être que
dans un contexte universitaire dans un
contexte professionnel dans un contexte
universitaire ou éducatifs canton c'est
une oeuvre on peut l'utiliser mais c'est
pas ça le débat
si c'est ça tout le temps se distingue
plus le temps de ramener le débat à
wimille
est ce qu'on peut parler du mot lui même
plutôt que des situations précises et
spécifiques où on pourrait quand même
l'événement qui a été l'élément
déclencheur
si je dis moi l'événement nov
je mens comment dire je peux dire je
veux toujours jugement fut mitigé donc
moi je m'en fous tout n'est pas ma place
mais c'est la conversation qui est
importante l'été autour de sheikh les
conversations qui qui en découle de cet
événement l'autre mais s'il faut que tu
arrives dans cette conversation là aussi
avec une une prérogative à m c'est
est-à-dire un d'avancé de conversations
l'heure avec des personnes noires side
pitié ne peut toujours mettre la
personne noire dans une position où elle
doit se défendre ou edouard cissé se
battre contre ta vision privilégié de la
liberté d'expression quand on a beaucoup
vu seul durant les moments où ce débat
là s'est passé soit on voyait que des
personnes blanches en parler en vue
d'amener dégonfler la situation puis
prendre des exemples spécifiques qui
sont considérés dit le bon mot de
l'histoire
ou bien tu avais des femmes comme
vanessa n'est destiné qu'à rêver au
téléjournal pis sentait devait
convaincre de la validité de ce qu'ils
vivent et puis heureusement elle le fait
de façon admirable mais je pense que tu
tentes ont parlé de fatigue je pense que
c'est ça aussi qui fatiguent les gens
qui sont militants et militantes
c'est qu'à un moment donné quand tu es
toujours en position de défendre puis
toujours en position te faire prendre
défaut ou de faire de te faire remettre
qu'on remette en cause chaque petite
partie spécifique de ton disque ça doit
venir toujours une entête de façon un
thème c'est le plus vieux truc c'est de
prendre ces d'un mouvement trouver ou
l'aberration outils la chose que tu
juges qui qui qui dépassent pour éviter
pour après se questionner ou invalider
une revendication c'est le titre et
qu'on le voit dans toutes les tous les
classements social ce soit n'importe
quoi c'est tout à ceux qui quittent
utilisent et non deux fois que je me
suis fait parler en parlant de gagny ce
melon de fois me souhaite parler des
inuit qui avait juste des phoques pour
se nourrir tes le secam pour qui pour
quoi tu parles tu fais quoi rapporter
turinois en ce moment qui est juste des
phoques pour se nourrir seul le point
médecine c'est sûr que l'argumentaire
spécifique mais j'ose à ussat pouces a
réussi vertus le temps des gens et
rhétorique métier je pensais quand on
parle d'enjeux qui avec des êtres
humains piegza révolution n'est ce pas
là d'une société ou d'un mode de vie
peut-être possible très bon là j'ai
l'impression que c'est vraiment
aucunement fondée le chp anthropologue
mais l'impression que c'est relativement
nouveau phénomène de mettre le ressenti
et l'émotion au pied d'égalité avec la
raison je peux faire ce que je veux dire
c'est que on dirait que de dire ça me
blesse ou je pense qu'on doit le tenir
en continuant d'inquiéter mettons que ça
devienne la civilisation et comme été
fondée sur la rationalité mais on le
tient depuis les grecs lotis non mais oh
oh non on ne l'arrêté plus c'est ce pays
on dirait que ça me blesse c'est presque
nouveau que c'est un argument qui est
qui valide qui est entendue puis c'est
pas encore entendu et acceptée par tous
bon je vois et je pense que c'est
peut-être la réaction première a dit je
pense qu'on on est tous comme cela en
tant qu'être humain on va se mettre dans
une position défensive rapidement quand
on se fait faire un reproche c'est ou
quand on est con front
il ya des émotions négatives qu'on a
suscité chez quelqu'un d'autre je pense
que souvent la réaction à 100 blessés
oui mais c'est parce que je voulais dire
dit tu me comprends mal un peu comme ce
que je disais tantôt alors que si ça
ferait de nous des globalement des
meilleurs êtres humains si on était
juste capable de valider les motions de
l'autre d'accepter d'accepter qu'on soit
même pas d'accord avec cette émotion à
l'heure mais qu'on puisse faire et je
comprends que tu vis valider cette
émotion à l'heure puis après c'est
d'avoir une conversation jeudi valider
la l'émotion le sentiment le ressenti de
l'autre si ces dissidents les deux
personnes s'aiment mais point de départ
d'une conversation rationnelle c'est
juste que je pense qu'on n'est pas
encore habitué à vivre cette validation
le plus on parle la situation du moins
un ennemi c'est dans nos relations
d'amitié dans nos relations
comment une relation professionnelle
c'est pareil partout mais je suis le
premier à être comme ce tir dans
l'impression quand il blesse quelqu'un
ou quand quelqu'un dit appauvri cette
affaire louche ça m'a pas plu ou la
façon de salive la première réaction du
projet pas voulu je profiterai pour mon
attention a d'abord été pris en défaut
alors qu'est ce que la personne te dise
et voici ce que moi je reste un range on
nous pour pas que ça se reproduise en
général c'est ce qui se produit ce qui
fait que les choses escalade
c'est quand on n'est pas capable d'avoir
cette admission le puits le conte
brouille les canaux de communication
puis quand on sait qu traque la
conversation que devrait avoir lieu ce
qui est arrivé à mon avis dans que
dumont est né dans bien d'autres
conversations des derniers mois sur les
les mouvements sociaux qui sont en place
c'est clair puis ça fait aussi écho avec
beaucoup de conversations sur la
communication piles et les les enjeux
communication qui à quel point j'aime
quand tu dis que les fabris le canal de
communication à quel point ces canaux
leçons sont fragiles sont importants
puis constitue l'essence même d'une
conversation consciente pied fille
castres puisqu'elle a en ce moment
puis ces canaux là aussi sont également
brisé de façon plus macro le tir dans le
dans le discours public ou est-ce que
leur 1/4 reproche quelque chose d'autre
à un autre qu'un plat au lieu d'en
discuter
on coupe les ponts
on se bat pour des conversations en silo
moins 50 fois c'est un peu ce qui est
arrivé pendant cycle débat toujours
juste l'exemple et puis encore une fois
le ce point reproche parce que je pense
qu'ils vont y est une question de mesure
sanitaire bien une question de logique
d'expression d d d d d d intervenants
sur son plateau
mettez la femme la fameuse émission tout
le monde en parle avec guy a lepage
quand ils ont reçu la preuve qu'ils ont
reçu avant impôts ils ont eu une
conversation avec elle la prof a quittés
ils ont su les quatre intervenants noir
a6 et après la pause mais pas de
conversation entre ces deux camps le
j'imagine qu'ils avaient une raison
pourquoi c'est arrivé
mais moi ça m'est apparu comme assez
évident que c'était une exemple
ification de la façon dont deux
représentations sont si lourds mais
n'ont pas jusqu'à me trouvais que les
deux entrevues était très nuancée 600%
les gens lèvent rien aux propos j'enlève
riom entrevue mais si vraiment ajusté
pour moi formation de qiu shi 6 pas
exagérer une impression de d'entendre un
cas c'est que je réussisse et intérêts
si on la voit quel genre de
conversations ces personnes le aurait pu
avoir entre réellement à gasquet si je
pense pas que ce soit une question que
d'après moi tu mets ton peut pas prévoir
en même temps je pense que c'était aussi
l'idée d'avoir quatre militants avec des
points de vue des positions concernant
différentes dans le grinch king of kings
mais quand même avec des sensibilités
différentes dépositions des façons de
s'exprimer aussi différentes primo ça
m'intéressait le danton d'autant ricardo
lamour qui militent valeurs que vanessa
que web stop j'ai pas l'impression
qu'ils se sont répétées que ce sont
camille de cannibaliser dans leurs
propos chacun chacune d'entre eux ont
mené la bonne nuance rex est ce plus
important aussi long mais n'est-ce pas
une pensée unique mais non
c'est ça aussi le reste une affaire
métier quand tu reçois le même piège la
personne de pommes texte n'est sur ces
affaires là au contraire une personne
ouvert puis je me sens parler mais c'est
vrai que souvent ces questions là
qu'arrive que la première chose le
premier réflexe que quelqu'un va avoir
c'est d'en parler la tester mon ami
machisu vaches combien voici ce que j'en
pense moi personnellement mais après ce
justement voir ce qu'il va exercer mais
je me souviens par contre dès que dans
la foulée de la crise au printemps
tarifs imposés pas tout avait dit mi mai
des hommes sont ouverts à danser sous
les communiquer aux jo tous les cons
discute unis faisant vous discutez pitt
y mettons je veux jamais écrits ou
appelé mon ami noir pour j'aurais qu'est
ce que tu penses de tal afar
parce que je ne veux rien imposer cette
responsabilité le soin que si mettons
dans le team si quelqu'un dit mémé
médiums sont ouverts ben le seul e
saison d'x une modification l
enseignement délibéré c'est à dire ça
parce que un peu comme je l'expliquais
tantôt ils l'ont partie de ma vie où
marié poser les questions que vous vous
posez en ce moment j'ai vu c'est comme
une balle chaude les j'aurais position
en faire puis j'ai eu pas de mettre le
pied dans la bouche où j'aurai juste pas
eu de réflexion par rapport à ce sujet
maintenant que tu arrivé dans ma vie
maintenant que je vois aussi la place
que ça prend dans la sphère publique
puis la façon dont les les gens de la
majorité blanche a de la difficulté à
comprendre ces situations-là bien à quel
point il ya peu de ressources aussi pour
avoir des conversations ouverte
décomplexée mais je me dis si moi je
cette personne le pour bien des gens de
mon entourage soviets
jje encore une fois je dis pas qu'il
faut que les gens fassent
il ya des gens qui veulent juste pour
être cette personne ressource là comme
il ya des femmes qui veulent pas être
cette personne ressource que pour des
hommes pour leur expliquer les lignes
féminisme les tenants et aboutissants du
féminisme et ses bains corée mais moi ça
me fait plaisir de cette personne la
pression je détiens pas la vérité refuse
absolument pas s'il va recevoir mon
opinion mais ça se peut des fois que je
fasse honnêtement aucune idée de ce que
je pense
la question que je me pose en ce moment
mais si je peux être le pont on est une
conversation puis si on peut être pas
dans le jugement non plus le sont plus
aussi moi qui est important c'est que me
dit si les gens me font assez confiance
pour me poser la question moi je leur
fais assez confiance pour qu'on ait une
conversation qui soit complètement
décomplexé qui se mettaient à 1 12 14
puis dans la bouche ce sera pas quelque
chose qui va faire qu'on va le canal de
communication que tu beaucoup de monde
crible durable que je pensais bah ouais
ouais moins que je pensais et c'est
assez surprenant quand même ça
surprenant je trouve parce que l'ère des
réseaux sociaux le puits puis
l'activisme de performance moi je lis
beaucoup ressenti pendant la performance
y paraître suspects et des gens noté que
je suis qui me suivent con que je
connais dans la vie qui vont publier de
nombreux stories des publications
fiction longue sa g des messages sur
leurs réseaux sociaux matin mais qui
vont jamais avoir commencé pour la
conversation avec toi parce que je
m'étais peut-être qu'ils ont avec
d'autres personnes que ça leur suffit
nous avons quand même surpris ce qu'il
n'y ait pas plus de conversation qui
soit abordée mais comment déceler qu'une
activisme et un activisme de performance
comment comment comment savoir
ben après c'est pour moi l'indicé c'est
une question de cohérence est ce que
c'est cohérent avec le message que tu
avais sont plates formes à vince avant
le jour c'est devenu rare de publier un
carré noir est ce que ces messages le
perdure aussi après le moment où tu as
décidé pendant deux trois jours d'être
ne pas une activiste puis d'en parler à
tort et à travers
puis c'est quoi ton actions concrètes
par rapport à ces enjeux le je pense que
le lit et comme certains éléments précis
je pense perdus de mauvais tours de
parole a répondu la question de très
bien
des nuances aussi personnellement je
peux toujours en train de faire france
emond panda machin machin mais il ya
aussi beaucoup de des actions que je
pose qui sont 0 public des affaires que
je fais pour moi et des toiles besoin
moi personnellement je ressens pas le
besoin d'en parler si quelqu'un me pose
la question je me posais la question va
en parler ça me fait plaisir quand je
sens que je peux servir à la
conversation je vais le faire à 100%
mais n'empêche que tu y mettons le
éducatrice et offriront le but tant
attendu dans le sens que si évidemment
il faut faire sa propre recherche
personnelle que l'information est
disponible le tir la formation
historique l'information il ya comme un
podcast comme une chose que tu peux
écouter pour pour en apprendre davantage
sans avoir à prendre le précieux temps
de tes amis autour de toi fac peut-être
que ça explique aussi le plus nombreux
possible de donner des aides ont été
reçus par ce que il était quand même
présent ces messages le 2 c'est pas la
responsabilité ni c'est à responsabilité
à toit de chaume informations sans pour
ça et après si je peux commencer ça m'a
pas heurter les gens viennent pas me
parler mais j'ai été surpris parce que
je me suis dit crimes post et il me
semble que les gens beaucoup de choses à
dire en ce moment stories puis là on
pressent conversation mais c'est
peut-être mais aussi qu'il est dur est
l'instigateur de ces conversations le si
je tenais vraiment les amours je sais
qu'un quand le mouvement black l'admr
est arrivé notamment de john floyd est
ce qu'elle est ce que tu étais optimisme
par rapport à un changement qui ce qui
allait arriver
puis après ça maintenant qu'on se
replace aujourd'hui est ce que t es ce
que tu crois que ça lui l'impact que tu
pensais que ça allait avoir
ou parce qu'on est revenue trop
rapidement dans dans une passe à autre
chose
c'est une question à laquelle c'est dur
de répondre parce que pour moi
personnellement ça changeait quelque
chose puis ça c'est à la fois inscrit
dans un cheminement amorcée depuis plus
grands quelques temps je suis pas un
spécialiste le métier je pense que par
exemple aux états unis oui ça va voir
changer quelque chose oui je pense
qu'elle est ici mis à avoir une vraie
réflexion sur la fonction la police puis
sur la fonction d'autres institutions
qui peuvent travailler en marge ou en
collaboration avec la police pour éviter
que ce genre de situation leur arrive
changer quelque chose
je ne sais pas ce que ça fait tout ça
pour que je pense que tu te sentirais
pas de ça ici c'est aller dans l'autre
sens il ya quelque chose qui avait
changé réellement on le sentirait
sûrement plus mais c'est le feeling que
j'ai on dirait j'ai le feeling que c'est
le parlement sera contribué à l'élection
joe biden possiblement wang et
possiblement difficile à dire mais mais
tombera à pors au quotidien la meuse à
avoir vraiment léger impact
je pense qu'au québec put me corrigera
sur notre homme mais je pense que le on
est plus sensible qu'on n'a jamais été à
leur représentativité dans les médias on
essaye fort dans la m quand je dis le
plus connecté je sais pas comment
arriver à destination mais je dis que
c'est mieux que vous la nappe c'est
mieux que vous le disais c'est mieux que
vous le cas j'imagine vraiment dur à
dire ce que je trouve que c'est quand
même
c'est comme regarder une toile de bain
pour dire que s'ils voient en ce moment
c'est une voiture décembre pas assez de
recul pour voir le dessin ans en paraît
dans un an qu'on aurait peut-être même
plus complète une meilleure idée de ce
qui va se passer parce que lens moment
j'ai l'impression qu'on est dedans on
est dans le moment où les gens font
monde prépare les actions qui vont avoir
un impact dans un trou au 6 9 12 - tu
vois ce que je veux dire un peu en
termes de médias je pense que les gens
font attention puis qu'ils essaient de
prôner la diversité qu'ils estiment en
avoir sur leurs émissions ou en tant
qu'intervenant petit mais j'aime pas sûr
encore qu'on a dépassé le rôle dit
aucune que qu'occupe la personne
racisées en général dans la sphère
médiatique est ce que c'est parce que
maintenant les gosses que les émissions
que les productions qui vont se voir
post blacklight marc besson j'entends
prod
en ce moment je sais je le cite pour moi
je peux pas dire que je le ressens le de
façon marquée dick est entrée avant le
mois de juin juillet puis aujourd'hui
qu'il ya eu un changement le radical
puis que soudainement la diversité et
est prise en compte et incarner je pense
que oui les gens font des efforts pour
avoir des personnes assises et des
personnes autochtones sur leur plateau
pour leur donner la parole mais moi je
les jeudis le depuis déjà un bon moment
je pense qu'à mon année outre l'idée
d'entendre ces gens là sur des enjeux de
la diversité ou de coach et à cause de
ça on une personne la diversité sont un
panneau sur notre plateau en ce moment
je pense que c'est de leur donner les
clés de la chaux exact donnez-nous les
clés de la chope d'année nous juste une
opportunité de se retrouver entre entre
personnes racisées pour ne pas parler
nécessairement de diverger sur ces
enjeux là mais pour créer du contenu qui
va juste donne une nouvelle perspective
parce qu'on peut parler des mêmes enjeux
dont ils vont parler à bonsoir bonsoir à
tout le monde en parle où as tu as fini
pied la semaine bleue
un matin il ya deux ans les émissions
soient les mêmes personnes
est ce que je dis c'est petit donne dit
pas des mêmes sujets avec des personnes
différentes qui ont des perspectives
différentes de par leur expérience de
vie de tintin show différent moi je
pense qu'on est potentiellement rendu le
jeu parce que c'est comme se dit les
choses sont vraies est réellement voir
changer quand que les personnes récits
seront pas juste ce qu'on met devant la
caméra mais ils sont aussi ceux qui
prennent les décisions en eau ce qui qui
créent les concepts qui écrivent les
chaussées seul le vrai gros défi ouais
tu veux si encore une fois le jeu pas en
train d t j'en veux pas au système parce
que le système existe de cette façon là
parce qu'on le laisser évoluer de cette
façon là mais s'ils s'y seul moi qui me
fascine c'est de me dire
et avant que je sais pas moi le
directeur ou la directrice la
programmation je mets un peu ça
s'appelle comme seul de radio can soit
une personne assise et c'est qu'un jeu
c'est pas le septet c'est peut-être
l'année prochaine était dressé jeudi
city cessé d'animer lui qui est à la
tête de radio canada fait une personne
j'imagine je sais pas si je m'égare là
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que je
pense qu'avant que avant qu'on puisse
clamer que la diversité aux triomphé
dans les médias je pense que ça va
falloir qu'on convoi des producteurs à 6
et on voit les gens qui prennent des
décisions qui sont réalisés pour fort
que ton coiffeur tamaki ruston tête des
personnes assises et aussi non ces
postes-là derrière le kodak à
réalisation dans un mobile à réaliser
des gros shows sa cellule c'est pas
juste parce que nous les faces
non non ceci comme tu dis
n'empêche que tu me trouves le 5 1 je
pensais pas qu'on serait indigne et de
bouquets naïma ton nom partout
effectivement faculté aujourd'hui sa
pause puis inaperçu c'était aucun effort
bâton puis sans bourse a déjà déjà été
demandée métier tu dis on ne voit on pas
encore au niveau du token métier encore
une fois ces mêmes questions pour
l'actif de performance comment savoir si
une réelle un réel désir d'inclusion au
juste il faut cocher une case pis toi
qu'as tu reçois un col comment tu fais
pour départager deux questions en très
nette un token ou bailly et les gens
vraiment envie de travailler avec
nicolas animateur mais je pense que ça
peut être l'un et l'autre pense que
c'est ça aussi le là la réalité si je
peins je pense pas que les gens vont
faire appel à des talents
un lait qu'elle y croit peu ou avec qui
ils veulent pas travailler mais je pense
qu' il peut y avoir un incitatif à nous
faire de la place parce qu on est issu
de la diversité parce qu'on est des
personnes assises et parce qu'on
représente un besoin métier on comble un
besoin à mettre à l'écran mettez moi
j'ai dit mais je les ai toujours dit le
par exemple ses jumelles je voulais
prendre les opportunités se trouve
refuserait tout quelque chose qui s'est
tu sens qu'il était temps bah si c'est
pour n'importe quoi là je vais refuser
quelque chose que je me sens pas en
capacité de faire le titre que s'ils me
demandait d'aller danser de la claque
est juste parce que parce que tu as
besoin de personnes comme je ne peux pas
danser la claque
revenir sur un sujet ou un autre ou
d'animer ou de collaborer des choses que
je capable de faire ouais voilà si comme
il ya tellement de choses je réfléchis
mais dis moi c'est parce que pour
répondre à ta question comment du
secteur aucune tu le sais jamais en fait
mais souvent tu peut en douter quand tu
poses la question quelqu'un qui en toi
dans la hiérarchie puisque la réponse
est évasive ou vaseuses puis c'est pas
grave moi c'est juste qu'il ya des fois
passé des conversations que j'ai eues
avec d'autres personnes assises et qui
font ce métier là jusqu'à des fois juste
pour notre gouverne en nous on aimerait
sans le savoir
puis c'est comme si parfois de cette
conversation le petit hic mais tim mom
et on attend dans ta perception de la
fayolle est ce que le fait que rune
l'issue la diversité ça ça a une
incidence ou est-ce que ça pis le la
personne mais non mais ton talent
machine que je crois mais moi j'y crois
en mon talent content qu'il croit aussi
mais le la question que je me pose c'est
est-ce que ya aussi une autre incidence
qui est le fait que je sois une personne
issue de la diversité c'est juste que ça
m'intéresserait de le savoir mais
souvent je me fais poser de questions
comme celle là où mich comme je le sais
pas c'est une impression c'est un
ressenti c'est un feeling qu'on a c'est
intéressant une fois que tu une faute tu
tombes dans ses questionnements le ca ya
qu un pas de fait on veut ça ne colle
pas trop où ça peut aller
c'est faux que tu t'arrêtes web 1,6 à la
force c'est ça le truc c'est ça aussi
qui est qui est difficile avec avec tous
et tous ces mouvements là qui arrivent
en même temps en somme les mouvements
sociaux qui arrivent en même temps tu le
sais je veux mettre mon énergie puis
monju mentale à réfléchir à cannes âge
peut être une meilleure personne par
rapport à sion mais on dirait qu'il faut
que je le fasse aussi par rapport à ce
qu'il a donné un petit peu dans toutes
les affaires puis tu devais notre
meilleur puis le meilleur quand tu fais
10 % dans quelque chose pour soi dans un
autre s'est jamais un 100% combler pour
ce qu'il faut que je fasse confiance au
processus et si ça prend du temps
ici c'est pas un coup de barre qu'on
peut donner le sein long c'est pour ça
que j'aime bien ce dont on parle est en
tout c'est dur pour moi de croire que
quelqu'un va être jour au lendemain
votre devenir toujours un militant un
ali en n'ayant jamais réfléchi qui
réfléchit à ces questions le enfin une
situation comme celle de droite dit je
pense que en fait c'est que le projet
tout ce que moi je suis sur les autres
mais moi personnellement dans la vie
chère mieux garder un peu le silence
m'éduquer de mon côté puis prendre la
parole si jamais j'arrive en forme au
dacia lmnp pas le faire mais savoir que
je me suis dit qu'est sur un enjeu que
de mettre la charrue devant un birdie
s'est montré pour la 6e fois qu'on l'a
vu mais c'est de plus en plus du
suspense de d'éviter des blocs de poser
ces questions le sait je pense que c'est
ce nous de notre ville et notre
génération c'est peut-être ma peau
situation là mais le jeune au secondaire
à montréal s'est posé ces questions là
et puis il y en a tant parlé puis ça
fait partie du débat nous public le
suicide c'est sur l'ailé les lits
justement les choux meanstream ce qui
n'était pas le cas vous le dise enlacé
son nom n'apparaît pratiquement pas donc
maintenant la question
la réflexion est presque inévitable
c'est au pas le choix moi je me suis me
trouve là lundi j'ai trente deux ans
puis je parraine à un comité de jeunes
justement tu es sur l'inclusion la
diversité chez tel jeunes 12 kid qui
sont extraordinaires la plupart issus de
la diversité mais de toutes formes de
diversité que ce soit actuelle
nicu à autres lots culturelles ou autres
quand je les entends parler quand je
pose des questions quand je vois à quel
point la réflexion et aboutit nuancé
complète informé jeu comme wow c'est fou
ce phénomène le de génération qui
achètent génération iv et j'ai
l'impression que change le monde qui
était petit en-avant sur la passe et
plus tu vieillis pilot avons une
jeunesse on a à peu près tout cela mais
moi je trouve qu'on a une jeunesse plus
confortable du point de vue des wii est
bon et élections oui des réflexions et
quel point qu'on se pose est moins une
question se posait pas question puis la
même personne qui challenge est nos
opinions et on apprécie t nous on in
quebec québec aussi c'est les 3 mettant
grandi à québec il ya peut-être aussi le
cette bulle ce microcosme qu'est québec
à l'intérieur la province qui par
différents je sais pas si les gens qui
ont grandi à montréal ont vécu une
expérience de fer autres parce que vous
venez quand je suis arrivé à montréal
puis le dans les dernières années avec
les débats qu'on ne vende ma jeunesse
puis je trouve que je suis pas ça trop à
côté d'une coupe d'affaires quoi
vraiment la cote et d'un coût de démoc
on aurait dû avoir plus d'une coupe de
réflexion qu'on aurait dû pousser plus
loin puis t d'aidé directe des
règlements dépensé que nous étaient
communiqués qu'on aurait dû remettre en
question mais tant québec j'ai souffert
non je voudrais pas ses ambitions
j'ai sincèrement adoré québec métier je
veux c'est pas grave mais j'étais
souvent québec j'avais l'impression que
tout va être différent comme tout le
monde
ouais je me suis dit soit tu peux pas
être différent différents moi dans ma
jeunesse je n'ai pas pareil mais ça les
jeux c'est le plus facile d'être comme
tout le mois c'est avait eu un accent
aussi tu arrives et et live d'une
culture des affaires
je repense à des trucs le type des
surnoms que j ai eu assez des affaires
et moi j'ai accepté loin à se passer
parce qu'effectivement si tu veux tu
peux d'intégrer droit comme tout le
monde se faire partie de la masse
si je pouvais si je m'attendais parler
le haut se gondole je me prendrais pas
facile
le nombre de choses que je peux répéter
ici qu'on disait couramment oui non mais
on le sait tous l'été c'est l'instinct
su que la référence et le moment est
floue sur tf1 avec avec ses parents
placés derrière seuil avait même pas le
début de conscience que peut-être que ça
pouvait blesser
finalement un aux amis qui étaient
homosexuels et dix passes qu'il a pressé
après si on a un ami qu'ils
appartiennent à croquer qui fait son
coming out après pays ont déjà une leur
ai dit pire s'arrête et ben correct qui
aurait été sur même été mieux jarraya
les fichiers c'est sûr que je vous parle
non c'est sûr et certain
on a on se donnerait le quelques bonnes
taloches moi ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que même moi je design
et maintenant tic avec que j'ai encore
aujourd'hui avec qui j'allais au
secondaire même aux primaires qui me
pose la question à ce jour
est ce que quand on était jeune j'ai dit
des trucs pendant earth et j'imagine
mais moi le poisson que je peux je peux
très rancunier infecté je me souviens
absolument rien puis je pense que je me
fie plus à l'aube de ma relation avec
ces gens là mais je trouve ça le fun
quand même qu'on soit capable même rendu
à à trente deux ans d'avoir cette
sensibilité l'ubs d'avoir une pensée
rétroactif
quand j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu blesser
mais remettons les pendules à l'heure
piti les shows justement qui était
connue communément acceptées dans ce
sens que prend le mans 7 heures thème à
un niveau inconscient mais c'est sûr
tandis que maintenant on est plus les
outils pour le nommer peu pour dire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
dit qu'est ce qui se dit pas tandis que
c'est sûr mais c'est sûr que n'empêche
qu'ils se soient dit joe que ça soit 6 à
des surnoms même s'ils ont l'impression
qu'ils étaient au repos toute sécurité
nous au jour le jour on se fait pour
rappeler les faits inconnus blanc il ya
pas d y dit même si pau mesquin même si
peu dans le but de blesser jeu à chaque
jour je peux contre confronté juin 10 km
elle je peux pas utiliser mauvaise météo
y confronter à la fois pris dans ses
contenus que la couleur la pole je parle
pas tous les jours parce que si on fait
un des petits cols du titre même si pas
méchant c'est comme à chaque jour entre
appels que tu es de faire mais moi c'est
ce qui me fait faire la paix avec l'idée
de pouvoir parler des enjeux qui
touchent les personnes auront les
personnes assises et parce que jusqu'à
encore une fois le pas si longtemps je
me disais ouais mais des chevaux suis
pas le bon le bon modèle de
personnaliser tout ce qui est bon très
justement québec j'ai grandi mais la
plupart de mes amis sont blancs est imam
blonde et blanches mais pas ensemble
c'est culturellement été très très très
québécois blancs très faible très très
très québécois blain
traditionnel visage peut pas parler
d'eux mais le jour où je me suis rendu
compte que chaque jour deux mois for
king vie jamais dit que je suis une
personne noire ou la vie ou la société
me rappelle que c'est une personne ne
fasse date que j'ai un accent québécois
où que je sois né à dakar ou à l'hôpital
saint-sacrement québec mes amis soient
blancs qu'ils soient arabes asiatiques
ou noir ou kers
mon expérience de vie et principalement
défini par le fait que je suis une
personne noire 6h12 pitt et j'en parlais
le type même pour mes parents le ça a
été une grosse surprise
dispo quand est ce que je racontais sur
m'étais je dit mettons ci sort de
quelque part qu'un sac à dos puis je
sais que j'ai l'opportunité de retourner
chez nous pour porter mon sac à dos
avant d'aller faire une commission dans
un magasin dans un centre commercial au
centre-ville dans la vie prix pandémie
je voyais aller porter mon sac avant de
rentrer juste pour pas avoir à gérer le
fait que j'ai peut-être me faire suivre
par un gardien de sécurité a les yeux
quelqu'un qui va me regarder
alors que moi je le sais que j'ai une
personne honnête seul ce genre
d'incident tous les jours de ta vie ou
presque sait qu'elle adore fois que tu
t'es dit que les portes et on sait
qu'ils croient vandales et sans tache
sur fond de la place lourd jamais c'est
ce texte même si on a grandi dans des
milieux presque identique le même
finalement c'est pratiquement deux
expériences de notre jeunesse
et quand le mot différents corps humain
absolument c'est quand j'ai vu tout ce
qui s'est passé souvenez en 2003 avec le
wolf pack ne tient plus du nom de
l'opération maintien le fameux
proxénétisme et c'est le prix de
l'opération scorpion scorpions ont
changé mon expérience de vie le c'est
aussi celle de mon frère aussi
c'est le sortir d'une pratique de soccer
à luçon d'achat en joggeuse puis en
survêtement puis trop possible puis nous
agréable vraiment poule on voit les
regards les faits le prouvent que
j'entends parler de tout cela évidemment
puisque le tilt est le journal de québec
passe par des phases de personnes noires
tarata des criminels et [ __ ] des
machins
pas comme incident c'est justement sur
un kit des gpo j'avais 2000 trouvais
j'avais 15 ans 14 15 ans mon frère en à
18,19 imagine on rentre dans le centre
d'achat le monde viennent de l'est et
non à la halte bouffe de place nous
l'argent m'a dit eh ben ouais ça va pas
non plus une petite chemise pour moi ça
ça eu une incidence sur ma vie en
général c'est comme le mettons j'ai un
perfecto j'ai un goodie ci prend des
photos de moi iasi en sisal de chemise
comme ce parce que moi j'ai toujours
internaliser qu'il fallait que j'aille
là le plus clean possible pour ces
foutus maltraité pendant le chemin d'un
coton ouaté peinture geek merkel partout
partout année qu'a jamais dit je veux
faire je me suis tu vois c'est tellement
je le dis souvent podcast mais c'est moi
mettons dans cette jeunesse le jeu pas
raciste est réglé c'est fou quand même
pas ce qu'était le ton expérience et aux
marmailles mais pas quand même place
mais clairement pour mémo tige
j'ai même pas capable de lui de le voir
deux de le reconnaître
moi j'ai toujours su que le racisme
existait mais j'ai jamais compris toutes
les ramifications exacte de ce qu'est le
racisme jusqu'à récemment
c'est à dire que oui je savais que ça se
pouvait se faire traiter de moyenne
parce que ça m'a tuer pour régulièrement
mais ça m'a pas plu celui ci dans le
sport évidemment il ya une propension à
ce que les émotions des bornes pièce qu
un ouf dingue de lens je suis à droite
arrivé à plus d'une reprise en est
arrivé dans la rue ça me d'agrément au
resto peu importe direct une situation
qui escaladent ça se passe comment
comment tu te sens tu es à ce moment là
le territoire colautti comme george
percy le nouëne on y avait beaucoup
mieux beaucoup de colère parce que ça te
ramène à une identité qui est pas choisi
dans t'es fier mais klopp a choisi me
suis dit pourquoi pas servi encore à la
définition via la charge de semoule
pourquoi toi tu peut dégainer ce foutu
mon rôle est de leur faire aussi mal
pourquoi tu possèdes c'est tant mieux
que moi je possède pas by jeu contente
pour la posséder parce que je voudrais
pas l'utiliser et le dollar c'est exact
c'est injuste que tu puisse utiliser
cette enveloppe parce que rien que je
puisse dire ou rétorqué à ceux qui soit
équivalent comme comme blessures ou
comme douleur je suis ce racisme là je
savais qu'il existait mais après c'est
le fameux racisme systems inc la façon
dont ces entortillé dans le système puis
dans l'expérience convient à tous les
jours en tant que personne racisées aux
personnes noires gelé compris au fur et
à mesure de mon expérience lui aussi
plus tu vieillis plus tu viens adultes -
te des passe-droits d'enfants plus tu te
rends compte que tu es noir thé noir
pinot noir aux yeux des gens puis c'est
pas toujours positives dans le monde
une fois que tu réfléchis au concept de
racisme systémique tu y penses pour de
bons essais de d'établir vraiment tout
la façon que ça peut s'articuler dans
société le c'est vertigineux comment le
problème est ancrée loin c'est capoter
mais comment j'allais juste juste le
fait que les gens qui gouvernent notre
province refuse de nommer le fait que le
racisme systémique existe c'est une
preuve que c'est drôle parce qu'ils se
débrouillent à chaque fois qu'ils sont
sur la question en entrevue il illustre
libéraux aux libéraux de la carte visa
mais bon la barre après un début 2011
débat sémantique c'est comme se
comportant le mot si le moins paraît
pourtant je suis juste un petit mot est
vraiment pas important
dilip ce fait plaisir à tout le monde
mais fernand débat sémantique on le vécu
pendant deux semaines avec le moment
personne ne sait rien non mais si tu dis
pop se refuse de le prononcer c'est
parce que le mot ya eu d'importants
effectifs toujours débout de mopi et
lalanne heures puis est ce parce que je
pense aussi qui est d'admettre que le
racisme systémique existe c'est
d'admettre qu'il faut faire quelque
chose il faut changer le sida on a parlé
avec notre échec indépendante que nous
notre job c'est tout après la mode de
ces choix
puis c'est exactement ça s'excite ajoute
les mots systémique c'est ok la
responsabilité c'est pas aux deux
individus arrêtés des traces ici pas
faim c'est comme à bas les taux une part
de responsabilité quelque chose qu'il
faut là dedans pour faire quelque chose
si tu pas aux femmes de table dans
depuis le tegra mine tout les niveaux de
90 sociétés exactement tous les paliers
qui existe dans notre société
piché se faut réformer ce soit il faut
réformer ce saut faut réformer 6e faut
réformer si c'est quand tu penses que
c'est quoi les liens ou 0 policiers
noirs on donne à québec spvq en à 0,12 à
effectuer pour moi c'est ça aussi c'est
comment la nuit
si on refuse de l'admettre qui aura fait
le racisme systémiques exige on retarde
le moment où on va vivre dans une
société qui équitable le port 1 c c'est
ce qui arrive puis en fait pour juste
step back un peu de tout se sait et
c'est vertigineux en ce moment à être un
instrument ça plane pour moi je dis ça
du plus haut de tous mes privilèges non
mais attends là mon sillage comprend la
l'on parle de mise en jeu de mots jamais
à travers tout sur le chemin
reste une personne extrêmement
privilégié métier on est on est tous
plus privilégie quelqu'un dont on est
d'accord c'est important pour moi qu'on
le reconnaisse aussi qui a été il ya
différents paliers après m6 est en tout
cas un valet de pas le fait que je peut
se parler de certains enjeux mais je
suis d'accord avec toi tu es juges
je pense qu'il le monde en ce moment
vient vertiges sont impossibles mais
chacun d'entre nous autour de la table
je suis pas mal prêt à dire qu'on est
quand même dans des contextes et des
personnes est un professionnel qui outre
sociaux et économiques qui sont
relativement stables vie relativement
privilégiés j'ai l'impression qu'ils
mettront dans ma vie qui arrivent
plusieurs affaires en même temps
plusieurs situations à gérer des fois je
des fois ça semble insurmontable tant en
termes de fardeaux mental puis le mans
la façon que je capable de me sortir de
ça c'était vraiment compartimente alizés
les affaires fait que j'allais devoir
régler ce dossier par toujours régler ce
dossier mais on dirait que haut niveau
la société on dirait qu'on veut pas se
permettre vraiment de régler les
affaires l'une après l'autre avec leur
tout ça arrive en ce moment mais ton le
blacklight madère les droits des
personnes autochtones
après c'est peut-être les droits de la
communauté lgbt qu plus apprécié que la
copie de l'ailé les gens qui sont et qui
ont pu les moyens de travailler tout
seul c'est tout à fait car il va même
temps mais l'on dirait que il ya comme
une jarre de séparation des priorités du
gouvernement puis je puis on dirait que
moi dans ma tête ça fonctionne pas
demain mais je pense que si un
dénominateur commun à tous ceux
c'est le fait qu'on a une propension à
avoir une courte vue sur la façon dont
on veut régler les uns en jute et oui on
leur met beaucoup d'eux de bandages
au lieu des villans le plancher la place
de réparer le chant et le tuyau long
remettre paul du silicone kanharith
c'est pas vrai look c'est la première
fois qu'on parle de chacun de ces enjeux
monde sait jusqu à chaque fois on fait
le choix d'y appliquer des mesures qui
sont souvent cosmétiques de dire qu'on a
satisfait la grogne pour l'instant qu'on
a satisfait le la demande pour l'instant
en attendant la prochaine fois où ça va
arriver jusque là je pense qu'on en est
à un point où on se dit ça ne peut plus
fonctionner
c'est la dernière fois c'est la dernière
première fois qu'on en parle mais est ce
que c est ce qu on a déjà frappé ce lieu
le le lieu collectif de dire la lola
cette fois le faut que ce soit la
dernière fois c'est dur parce que moi
j'ai l'impression que moi c'est mon
sentiment c'est que c'est la première
fois dans ma vie à moi qui en suis dans
une chute dans une posture je me dis le
c'est terminé faut que ça se termine il
faut qu'on règle les enjeux climatiques
il faut qu'on règle et les enjeux de
discrimination raciale faut qu'on règle
les enjeux discrimination envers les
communautés lgbt
j'ai plus envie d'attendre parce que je
pense qu'on devrait déjà 38 le métier
c'est sûrement juste parce que j'ai
l'âge que lorsque tu le vive parce que
j'ai assez d'expérience pour me dire que
le mont et 47 en appui de bornes ça
avance clairement poussé vite qu'on le
voudrait que ça de vrai mais je pense
qu'à chaque fois qu'on a parlé c'est
quand même un petit peu plus petit peu
plus en avant pis tu regardes historique
mangerait strict m'en voulez pas si
longtemps je dirais y avait il y avait
la ségrégation
ça c'est fou quand même souvent ça
m'arrive de penser
vraiment pas si longtemps s'il ya pas si
c'est pas loin non c'est froid 30 ans à
peine 60 c'est qu'on a affaire à un sac
plastique et personnes vivant qui a mixé
dans l'histoire récente le cefac ses
quatre gardes suisses gala trajectoire
que tout prend son ami et sinueuse pee
wee à la bave pas assez vite mais je me
dis au moins un crime j'ai l'impression
qu'on on recule pour ne reculer pendant
le 4 mai la g droit khl mais voudrait
car les plus vite mais bon c'est dur
d'être patient c'est une raison d'être
patient quand on est dans la force de
l'âge comme on line wam
c'est dans le sens où on est on a toutes
les opportunités possibles
on ne la flatte physique la force
mentale l'énergie de mettre l'épaule à
la roue pour que les choses changent de
pour utiliser un anglicisme puis ce ne
sera pas plus vite parce que nous on est
discret non si nous on fait notre chemin
autant que autant que les boomerangs
états unis ont fait lors de sa main le
type apprécié de loi reprend le flambeau
enfin bon puis après avoir passé le
flambeau à la prochaine puis maintenant
si par contre la génération qui nous a
précédés avaient autant confiance en
nous que moi j'ai confiance en m non
c'est ça parce que l'eau on les voit les
jeunes cons on les voit les lieux non
mais à quel point sont en guinée ou
autre seppi j'écoutais j'écoutais
commence à s'ennuyer avec corneille dans
son bocal qui quittent excellent ballon
quel homme croyant mon idole de jeunesse
je peux pas vous dire à quel point qu'on
a parfois les messins en anglais puis
lydie je regarde regarde son fils de 10
ans ça donne espoir au bout tu ne sais
pas ce qu'il lui cham à ces questions le
d'inclusion de cixi que mal réglée en
guinée dans sa tête c'est comme si c'est
juste normal puis fax est ce que ça
donnait ce porte c'est sûr qu'après ce
crime haïti mettons nos parents nos
grands-parents jeudi c'est le clergé
d'autres pilotes
c'est d'une minute mais c'est moi j'ai
comme je dis les choses croit touche le
gros bol de cette belle dame que la
génération qui nous suit sa génération
qui va régler une grosse partie des
enjeux auxquels on fait facilement les
régler avec notre rêve - c'est une chose
qui est sûre par exemple les enjeux
climatiques environnementaux on pourra
pas attendre que les postes décisionnels
pour que ça se passe c'est maintenant
qu'il faut ça se passe mais c'est leur
énergie qui devrait nous porter à faire
ses affaires
comme je disais en tout c'est quand jose
avec les où les jeunes du comité des
jeunes chez tel jeune j entends parler
de 6 ans je le puis de voir leur
réflexion puis de voir à quel point ils
sont capables aussi de comprendre
concrètement ce qu'ils peuvent faire
pour faire bouger les choses
c'est hyper rassurant après ce qu en
mauges a redit ce que je vous ai dit ça
j'ai jamais eu confiance en une
génération comme j'ai confiance dans la
vôtre ils sont par une fois encore c'est
vrai qu'on a les réseaux sociaux c'est
vrai que on est capable on eu l'air
globalement collectivement walk
mais ce pauvre est que tous les gens de
notre entourage sont des personnes se
soient contribuer la conversation pisa
sion qui se doit d'être qui doit être
fait avec faut quand même pas abandonner
cette éducation le crime que moi je
suivrai n'importe où gsk sans larron un
problème dans la société dans laquelle
on fonctionne par rapport à ceux c'est
que quand tu regardes mettons le les
élus politiques ou est-ce que notre
tranche d'âge se retrouve où il y en a
quelques-uns deuxième temps allons voter
si j'aime bien
les gens qui se présentent non non je
constate un brin expérience politique
l'expérience politique est acquise avec
le temple le temps affecté dans une
génération en intensité la motivation
aussitôt le feu au cul là je pense âgé
de la bande le kaki ou parti libéral du
canada avec qui j'allais au secondaire
mais ça ça dit rien sur les allégeances
politiques personnelles quand je regarde
ce que le canton avait 8 9 10 ans disait
moi un jour je devenais un premier
ministre du canada qui aujourd'hui est
député bien un rôle important au sein du
parti libéral au sein du gouvernement
mais dit quand tu veux tu peux en france
dit vous allez voter hier j'ai regardé
les statistiques 66% taux de votation
2018 aux élections provinciales à pine
50 % des moins de 35 ans voter sinon
problème parce que je faisais ces
problèmes on se plaint on veut du
changement petit tube puis on a beaucoup
critiqué les institutions je comprends
que les institutions sont pas adaptés à
la façon dont on mène une vie dont on
conçoit la société mais là les
institutions elles existent comme tel si
on veut l'échanger
c'est un cliché de dire ça mais si on
veut l'échanger il faut qu'on s'implique
pour s'impliquer bien le premier geste
c'est d'aller voter fin et golly chomon
ses parents vont voter qui ils sont plus
de chance d'élire leur petit chemin
politique jamais la personne qui leur
présente les représente le plus parce
qu'ils votent en plus grand nombre c'est
réellement notre problème pile là on a
un poids démographique important ta
commençons par la base aussi bon il faut
quand même croire à ce système le puits
vouloir y participer et puis j'ai pensé
que peut-être que notre génération se
sent moins interpellé par home ont
peut-être moins cet appel lancé parce
que cinq essais il peut faire une
différence ailleurs autrement c'est par
les militantismes par la politique
intimité mais ça y est pour beaucoup le
des teams et on y est je pense que je
suis une personne à qui je pense que je
me dis ces personnes-là mettons
par la mise en jeu qui me touche de
citron catherine fournier a vécu pendant
mais qui est vraiment que je me dis
mettons ce qui moi le travail mais
préoccupe peu d'eau qu'ils amènent
pillon td beaulieu puis propose des lois
pour que ça change
changement si justement il ya plein de
javel exemple graines fournies parce que
je trouve que souvent béton il ya des
polémiques des caméras utilisent les
lits dénonciation cailloux mettons la
montée vraiment dit qu'on sentait le
montage conspirationnisme ces
problématiques
puis comme est connecté à un peu plus
sur les raisons qui aimait tant françois
legault le petit bain être plus
rapidement ces espèces de mouvements là
ces espèces de nouvelles d'une
revendication alternative mais tant
qu'on ne connaîtra pas d'aller dans les
grands médias souvent cm tous comme la
fin des habits trio on entendu parler
avant d'elle sur les réseaux sociaux que
ses traditionnels puis c'est souvent
comme cela s'était déjà rendu au genou
ces réseaux sociaux c'est vrai je trouve
que c'est ça ça m'apprend plus que m
holt et déjà qu'ils sont en phase avec
ce qui se passe le dal dans la jeunesse
pjj en laine cela baup qui propose eloi
picard des bacs picchi sur quitter je
suis pas la personne la plus férus sur
la façon dont fonctionne le système
politique que les caucus je me dis que
si statistiquement tu vois que les gens
qui ont voté pour compte en partie ce
sont des gens qui sont majoritairement
des générations xy this way étant dans
un système particulièrement
électoralisme la fausse solution
c'est sûr que tu vas de rédiger mon ton
attention vers ces gens là n'est pas
payante ou dans votre poche c'est un bon
point
c'est un c'est un excellent point de vue
je l'avais pas vraiment vu comme ce
avant que le verbalisent juste le met
vraiment d'accord par exemple que plein
d'autres chemins à emprunter pour faire
du changement aux cris du changement
dans la société
mais c'est tellement simple vous allez
voter même enseigne aux dernières
élections fédérales
ça m'a pris deux ça m'a pris deux
littéraire littéralement piste alternant
prix à montfort d'aller à ce qui était
juste à côté de chez nous débarquer dans
le monde ont signé puis revenir aussi je
me suis que je mettais prévu si j'avais
bloqué battue qu'est-ce qui fait savoir
toi qui leur attraction le et et autant
de sujets thomas le militantisme des
réseaux sociaux qui fait que ces gens là
sont les jeunes sont aussi éveillé
honnêtement je pense que les réseaux
sociaux y sont pour beaucoup
et le j'ai l'impression qu'on parle en
un dieu bonne j'ai l'impression que les
réseaux sociaux ils sont pour beaucoup
je pense qu'ils sont sensibilisés à un
grand nombre dangereux
je pense qu est-ce qui est le grand défi
pour cette génération là de ce que j'en
entends c'est de les encourager à contre
vérifier les sources d'information qui
qui reçoit fut aussi à approfondir les
recherches puis leur leur nom lidge sur
les enjeux qui revendique mais j'ai
l'impression que ça va se faire
naturellement mais que ça se fait
naturellement siens en vieillissant puis
au fait de les intéresser les réseaux si
c'est le meilleur du pays en même temps
dans les deux cas pas de départager le
bon du mauvais typique regarde juste le
bon sens et c'est merveilleux et
s'intéressant aussi la façon dont ils
perçoivent tous les influenceurs pis je
sais que c'est une grosse question de
bien gros des bols de l'incident était
le nom de code dans notre génération
leur rôle des influenceurs petits
métiers ce que j'aime c'est qu'ils
voient pas les choses comme étant
mutuellement exclusives c'est à dire je
ne dis pas parce que un jour dessus
ventre
je ne sais trop quel produit que le
lendemain je croirais pas ce que tu dis
sur un enjeu mais ce qui est bien
important semble-t-il pour eux c'est la
nation de cohérence dans le message qui
est envoyé par les gens qui suivent sur
les réseaux sociaux
puis ça ça me touche bien gros parce que
je pense que particulièrement dans notre
génération ont été rapides à mettre une
certaine partie des gens qui gagnent
leur vie ou qui vivent elles une
certaine expérience professionnelle sur
les réseaux sociaux les met dans une
catégorie qu'il a et décrédibiliser un
peu comme ce que fait geneviève peterson
avec elisabeth riou par rapport à
d'autres enjeux sur lesquels ils ou
elles vont prendre parole de voir que
les jeunes sont en mesure de faire la
distinction entre tous ceux moi je
trouve ça rassurant que si une journée
ce que c'est de contenir après si une
journée du sud il n'a pas de bon sens
l'environnement il faut faut faire
découvrir leurs actions concrètes piqué
la menthe fine peu pour une pétrolière
quand c'est exact c'est l'autre point
tantôt que je l'amenais de dire j'ai
l'impression maintenant c'est juste que
donner tout le monde un peu sa
plateforme
tout le monde peut quand les autres la
rumeur shit de quelque 1 600 bourse
suisse axa ça participe en fait à
l'espèce d'effervescence intellectuelle
pi ou des générations qui ont soudain
moins en un sens et puis je m'inclus ada
aussi lorsque ça pour ça même si on est
un peu plus vieux que ce sauf que reste
qu'en 4 400 mille personnes qui peuvent
te répondre puis calé sur une bouche id
des trucs pour réussir à passer de la
bouche et à tout le monde un sentiment
d'imputabilité
c'est la chose la plus précieuse si tu
utilises bien des plateformes exact puis
le truc que tu que je voulais juste
ajouter quand tu parlais de que le monde
regarde c'est pas parce que tu vends
quelque chose dans le genre que ton
opinion est invalide
la publicité le ca existe pas nouveau
depuis tout le temps toutes les
émissions de télé toutes les choses que
les chaudes radio tout ce que tu as
écouté depuis qu'il est tout petit sur
lesquels tu te bases et d'un opinion x y
ou z
il était payé par la publicité 100%
texture cosnac contre consommer du
contenu gratuit comme étant en ce moment
le monde qui coûte le poker à la forme
du contenu gratuit
ben écoute on vend de la pub sur les
podcasts pour être capables de le
produire c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne comme ça que ça marche c'est
comme ça pour ce que j'ai fait c'est
vraiment la question de cohérence dans
les choix que tu fais des partenaires
que tu vas voir nos points de vue
commercial c'est juste sur ce qu'il faut
penser que les influençable le taux à
terme large et est sujet à des bonnes
médecine mettant les gens seraient
censés se fondant devrait dire sauf pour
tous les termes ce terme là qui est
large et sujet à débat c'est une
personne
ces bons seraient fermés sujet à débat
ces prêts toxiques afin d'en agresser
c'est un endroit où les gens vont aimer
pour manger c'est la restauration
complète et éviter
mais ce qui est vrai a pas pire c'est
que c'est ces gens l'aiment et en font
même erreur trier près il y en a pas
d'incohérence mettre le pied dans la
bouche on les critique puis tout le
monde apprend finalement à l'enfant et
lui ai dit publiquement mes thèmes ou
des enfants je les en prix mais je viens
d'apprendre que je peux dire c'est pour
ça que c'est quand même année des
espèces de gens qui ont été
littéralement les rats de laboratoire de
l' influence ou une maison c'est quoi
les limites de ce que tu peux partager
la façon dont tu peux le partage et
autres pardon c'est quelque chose que
j'allais dire donc oui c'est en fait je
pensais au au fait que tim est donc en
tant qu'antenne juste pour le canton une
plateforme comme comme la tienne comme
celle d'autres influenceurs et aussi
l'idée de on apparaît tantôt de
l'imputabilité puis du fait qu' il ya
une espèce de distance ou un quatrième
mur qui a été abattu qui existait à
vendre les vedettes tous les gens connus
et leur public tu dis ça pour moi c'est
ça une grande valeur par la cause la
relation que ça permet de tisser en ce
public et ces gens là mais ça comporte
aussi un énorme risque était c'est le
risque quand on parle depuis tantôt
c'est à dire si tu décides de sherritt
des sites de partage et décide de faire
la promotion de produits ces gens là tu
leur pari de pagnes ont l'impression
d'être dans ta vie tu as l'impression
d'être dans leur vie mais du moment où
tu fais une erreur ça pardonne pas mal
moins tu fais un faux pas dans une
entrevue dans un show sur une grosse
chaîne se tenait deux tablettes et
pendant une année ou deux jours le
tendeur de développer nos projets ou à
l'hymne être d'aller sur une autre
chaîne
mais quand à plateforme c'est instagram
et que ton vecteur de communication
c'est toi même ça fait que se fixe pas
vraiment plus à ton nom personnel mais
n'empêche qu'ils triment les comédiens
connus qui fait une pub de change de
dire c'est pot il joue pas le rôle de
quelqu'un qui te voir charlotte et c'est
lui qui devant sharp arrêts et puis
prend la décision pillés tandis que les
enjeux éthiques
il était déjà le film atypique puis
mettons on a parlé un petit peu plus tôt
et avec les hommes et si tout était déjà
là c'est juste le médium que changer
examen sens que c'est une question de
code sandy code qu'on a appris à
accepter mais c'est comme parler de la
marijuana puis de l'alcool la même chose
les codes autour de l'alcool on les a
acceptées d'une certaine façon pilule à
la main
rejoignant le weed arrive dans nos vies
plomb développe des nouveaux canaux bout
du compte des deux drogues des
partenaires étaient connus qui se
servent leur notoriété pour te vendre
des produits puis porté à retirer des
pièces d'or l'été puis
et qu'on s'intéresse tout c'est leur vie
personnelle c'est papa but avec heinze
taiwo existait déjà
c'est la question contrôle je pense que
c'est principalement ceux là là la
grosse différence pour 70 ou se dit ici
c'est ce que je respecte mais aussi du
travail chez des gens qui qui qui qui
principalement gang leur vie à travers
les réseaux sociaux si tu trouves la
fine ligne en discutons envie de
partager parce que t'as pas envie de
partager de ta vie personnelle de ta vie
professionnelle de ce qui t'entoure put
se met il ya juste toi ou presque qui
est en contrôle de ses deux se partagent
le type de cette ligne look tués tandis
que je sais pas quelqu'un qui fait une
entrevue dans sept jours dans les coûts
vedette qui a un agent qu'une agente
machin et des gens pour quand même une
force un espèce de 206 de boucliers
protection autour de la delà de la
personnalité publique t c'est clair que
je donne une ligne éditoriale d'un et
l'histoire quand tu es série de sociétés
ton propre et de stands s'il ya personne
qui va venir te voir faire pareil
ce texte puis ça c'est le premier
message d'amitié mais j'ai trop - après
ce la seule personne qui va retirer des
profits de tes décisions comment tu
décides de mettre en scène c'est toi moi
sorti pour ceux qui on va te mettre à
l'avant pied du monde le ddd des hommes
qui sont en vie plein les poches avec ce
tir qui a cédé par alp tandis qu'il a
décidé de mettre enfin de certaines
façons de porter plus ou moins de
vêtements selon ta décision betty au
moins c'était un contrôle c'est toi qui
m'était propre limite c'est toi quartier
les écumes bénéfices mois mais les
bénéfices quand c'est les bénéfices les
conséquences et des concerts prend plus
de risques exacts pour + 2 pour 1
potentiellement plus de bénéfices mais
aussi des potentielles conséquences
adresse e
après sa 17e décide des gens qui ont des
gros favoris comme ceux qui se disent
ceci de la responsabilité qui ont à voir
leur public ça je pense que tu peux pas
facile parce que tim ream study bay mais
j'ai pas choisi moi d'avoir deux cent
mille abonnés c'est juste que je fais
sopi les gens me suivent dans l'anarchie
jamais revendiqué d'être un exemple quoi
que ce soit fade mais je peux donner
dans la réalité tu en as une chose tenez
un exemple même si t'as jamais voulu
naître
tu es le seul cas où ça pourrait être
acceptable comme explication c'est
quelqu'un qui réellement ne s'est jamais
servi de sa plateforme pour obtenir un
bénéfice plus bénéfice quelconque dans
sa vie c'est juste deux cent mille
abonnés sans jamais s'arrêter possible
le thé au début des réseaux sociaux
quand c'était beaucoup plus 10 en
organique dont les gens pouvaient tomber
sur tf1 avec sa grosse cette façon
exponentielle vraiment rapidement mais
aujourd'hui si par des 0 32 cent mille
psy et en a obtenu aucun bénéfice
si c'est ça qui donne un exemple
paraître et pitt était responsable de
100% d'eads et des valeurs que tu que tu
transmets vraiment fait qu'on ne doit
aussi de les critiquer quand on juge qu'
on est en désaccord sur tout si tu joues
sur la proximité c'est moi c'est ce qui
me dérange ray le plus quelqu'un se
dédouaner d'avoir une responsabilité
envers son public excepté justement pour
te rendre à 1 201 coussins ou peu
importe le provost gagner des abonnés
c'est sûr que tu joues sur la notion de
proximité avec les gens qui te suivent
que vous êtes en tout et dans leurs vies
sont avides je leur donne l'impression
du moins d'être dans ta vie le cas
précis de des doigts d'être dédouanés
puis d'avoir l'impression que tu aucune
responsabilité envers je crois pas tant
que ça
c'est clair je veux qu'on revienne sur
l'onglet qu'on est ouverte tantôt deux
tons entre le carnet de commandes
comment te sens tu dis que tu as une
idole de jeunesse mais j'imagine que tu
es heureux le rencontrer incroyable tout
la rencontre avant c'était la première
fois que je le rencontrais t'imagines 32
dans une vie fourré
si j'en ai parlé dans son podcast mais
c'est pour moi connais certains un vrai
un vrai modèle visible c'est quand tu es
jeune justement qui grandit dans un
milieu il ya pas beaucoup de diversité
où il ya peu de gens qui te ressemble à
part mon frère qui a été d'ailleurs mon
second modèle parce que je l'aï suivi
dans à peu près tout ce qui est fait
dans sa vie en étant jeune
tu as besoin de voir que quelqu'un qui
te ressemble t outre outre ce qui fait
ce qu'ils chantent plus injuste que
quelqu'un quitterait sans emploi est un
modèle positif peut exister dans la
sphère publique parce que c'est dit j'ai
souvent eu cette conversation là avec
certains des amis ils estiment qu'ils
sont blancs villard 10 était jamais toi
tu te demander pourquoi tu trip sur brad
pitt ou leonardo duque rap dicaprio
princpaux identitairement physiquement
vous pour rassembler plus ou moins bref
petit identité cette personne moi je
peux m'identifier cette personne là
parce qu'elle est mais tel ne résolvent
là où tu en avais dessus j'en ai jeunes
non je me suis rendu compte de ceci est
vraiment venu plus tard c'est baky et la
plupart de mes idoles dans mon métier
c'est des gens qui sont blancs comme on
parle de john chambers deux lots charest
tout qu'importe
mais c'est vraiment tenu plus d'un point
de vue professionnel puis l'exécution du
travail que des idiotes et viscérale
d'intérêt de j'en sais pas pourquoi du
strip anticipe puis corneille a fait
partie un peu de ces gens alors déjà je
voulais m'habiller comme lui je vais
avoir des cheveux comme lui je voulais
chanter comme lui parce qu'il y avait
quelque chose de magnétique c'est une
influence positive
ça me démontrer aussi que c'était
possible d'exister dans la sphère
médiatique public en étant une personne
comme comme ce que j'étais ou que je
suis ce que je suis encore une personne
noire qui moisit fait pas ou que très
jeune je savais que je voulais faire
exactement ce que je fais aujourd'hui
mais très jeune j'ai su que ça allait se
passer dans satisfaire le cpie j'avais
besoin d'avoir des modèles à quelques
pas c'est vrai que c'est une bonne
réflexion de dire si ton en fait ça ça
amène encore plus de façon plus
pertinente la question de la
représentativité parce que effectivement
ton idole viscérale que que tu veux je
suive à tout prix c'est un kit sans fil
fixe ça ça c'est ce raisonnement leur
amène sur un an +2 de l'avant plan des
publications sur instagram sur techtoc
de parents qui filme et leurs enfants
avec des statuettes de peinture c'est
pour moi c'est exactement ce mois n'y
avait pas de black panther quand j'étais
jeune je suis sûr et certain que si ça
avait existé qu'en jetons jeunes par
quatre si j'aurais capoter jamais trouvé
ça super et au manque d'intérêt parce
qu'il me ressemblait pas mais c'est sûr
que ça une certaine incidence
j'espère est qu'on soit tous des
gobelins musclée en quatre grands mots
me reconnais pas là-dedans c'est fou non
non sipho l'importance culturelle de ce
fait mieux puisque savent à présent
c'est à manger quand j'allais voir ce
film le haut au cinéma outre le fait que
c'est un excellent film non plus mais
encore là dessus et il pleure et
montgueux loin pour aucune raison bien
même temps pour toutes les raisons du
monde te sentir visible ce moment-là
mais d'aller voir black panther les
adhérents qui ont trouvé ça super
vulgaire comme comparaison la marée voir
black panther c'est l'élection de barack
obama en 2008
ce discours de la semaine dernière moi
c'est des moments clés dans l'expérience
d'une personne noire qui
qu'ils peuvent pour elle refait qui sont
déterminantes pour la suite des choses
semblent tellement rare dans la culture
mainstream qu'on célèbre la culture
africaine honnête ça laisse arrive
presque jamais c'est comme moi on n'a
pas le pont on la connaît pas plutôt un
film qui va qui s'élève cette culture le
temps de la musique si telle greffe la
musique de tustin tout est un suédois le
nom mais italie crise du monde afrique
qui a utilisé des instruments qui a pris
la musique puis le fêter à en partage
bien métissage phi phi choisit quand
même si je ne m'abuse kendrick comme à
la production exécutive de cette trame
sonore le tc the big and rich pour le
premier extrait qui est sorti il ya des
choix conscient de représentativité de
la culture noire qui passe juste
justement autour de cette conversation
le à propos de la diversité etc c'est
aussi la force de ce club c'est ce qui
fait que ceux ci forment servir ce qu'on
disait tantôt c'est même tu regarde un
film qui est en train de te dire où
c'est personnages sont en moi des enjeux
autour de leur vie sont existe parce
qu'ils sont noirs et c'est juste leur
univers et sa mise en valeur
je connais 0 mettons-les lille et les
deux soucis qui derrière ce film là mais
j'ai pas l'impression que c'est un
record de des blancs sociaux j'ai
l'impression que les artisans ce fameux
là je sais pas mais il est patent que
j'ai car leurs gardes
c'est que c'est vraiment la communauté
100% le j'oublie le nom du réalisateur
mais c'est définitivement un homme noir
qui étaient relativement jeunes aussi un
mendiant je me faire tirer des tomates
mais bref
même chose quand j'écoute pas un
personnage noir dans leur garde blâme
relâchement dans la gorge
c'est simple ça exactement ce que je
disais tantôt tu peux pas faire d des
films on crée du contenu avec des gens
qui sont issus de la diversité puis
espérer que cette diversité le soin
incarne il ya s'exprime de façon
organique
si au port un six pièces autour de ces
gens là pour leur permettre de
s'exprimer comme y sont les codes
pigiste pas un reproche que je fais en
ce moment mais les codes qui existe dans
la façon dont on crée du contenu sont là
comme ça en général particulièrement les
médias traditionnels ils ont été créées
par des personnes morales dont ils ne
connaissent ou et elle ne connaissent
rien d'autre vaccine normale soit celui
ci reproche non plus être sûr mais si ça
fait partie de notre famille racisme
système et djourou dans le producteur ou
temps un diffuseur août un représentant
d'un diffuseur qui est une personne
assise et marché qui comprend les codes
comprendre langage comprend
l'interprétation de ce que tu m'as à
l'écran soudainement tu es complètement
ailleurs
parce que tu une réelle conversation et
une réelle compréhension petit de de
faire comprendre une expérience de tower
ou la somme d'une expérience ou la somme
de ton vécu qui s'exprime à travers ton
travail en mots à quelqu'un qu'il ne
jamais vécu c'est compliqué en inde à
barrow mairie puis pour trouver les les
lébous pense pas que ça c'est plus de
trouver les lélés les bons mots puis la
bonne la bonne sémantique justement pour
arriver à faire comprendre à quelqu'un
qui n'a aucune idée de cette expérience
c'est exactement ce que tu veux faire
quand tu dis et moi j'aimerais ça faire
on joue avec des personnes issues de la
diversité et où racisées puis se soit
pas à propos de ce complexe
il y en a ont contraints à voir des
shows que c'est ça l'esprit mais pour
québec encore cm du show beach où les
choses sont très avancés sont en avance
sur nous autres c'est andres est plus
ancrée de plus normal cette diversité
l'appui on a besoin de langlade
mes shows préférés des dernières années
cpu à dact avec rassemble ménage lui
l'humoriste indo américaines puis
c'était sister un talk show sous un
magnifique plateau il faisait du temps
un exploit d'une demi heure mais dans
son public lui est un indien dans son
public était majoritairement des blacks
enron pipeau je n'ai pas pour faire des
blagues à propos de ça pour faire des
références à propos de son expérience
d'immigrants leçon l'expérience avec ses
parents petit puis moi de regarder un
show comme ça ça m'a tellement fait bien
parce que tu serais enfin tu es des des
blagues ou une façon de s'exprimer une
façon d'aborder des sujets qui exclut
avec par la majorité blanche et kim a
inclus moi d'abord et avant tout puis
d'enfoncer ce que tu te rends compte
c'est que souvent quand tu regardes des
shows de télé qui sont faits ici ou
ailleurs sud cinq hommes cité curial
femme diana est bloquée ne comprends pas
ça fait pas un contenu moins bon c'est
jusqu'à 100 propre bande tpo coeur de
l'expérience de ce show le voeu de faire
vivre
bignone vrai différent tu montres que tu
ce que je souhaite dans le futur c'est
de pouvoir voir des choses qui m'ont
fait revivre ce à des jeux a demandé
génération qui nous qui me suis fait
bref quand tu vu le trench coat à cornet
étaient à la tâche tellement j'en parle
à ma main après jane eyre par la main
après 100% se souvenait très big mommas
like les décors knight a fait jouer ce
match je trench coat semble à mon talent
est aussi mise à place ste-foy
où tous mes amis ont travaillé seul ami
qui arrivait avec des cravates au
secondaire parce qu'il travaillait chez
soi et mal à l'ego qui toujours des
soupes trop grand l'espèce de gilet de
laine ligne est dommageable sauce il est
pétri de folk au total
marc cherry pie dans l'autobus le puits
avait trois gars qui aime son pays on
sera bientôt de rochas les bus il y
avait trop de monde d'aller dans des
friperies commandé en alignant même on
est des enfants des années 90 ouais tu
m'as tout mon habit de balle c'est aussi
ma totale bonne réputation
moi j'ai encore mon habitude j'ai fait
dans la douche et nous facture comme
tout mis dans des nids boîte fait des
aides et des deus un seul et j'ai
retrouvé mon avis deux balles une
horreur sans nom une horreur sans nom
que en plus probablement que tout jamais
reporter jamais en a faux faux faux les
reporter une fois mais je les reporter
en partie mais jamais la totale c'est le
veston bleu poudre les pantalons blancs
les souliers blancs la chaîne pantalon
blanc souligne le site est allé
m'excuser et on le fait qu'il m'apparaît
on sent déjà mais parle mais c'est
surtout la cop10 mettons oui j'ai
reporté une couple de fois mais si
j'avais 16 ans je des poésies 15 livres
de moins pire encore mais qui est trop
grand
c'est ça j'ai trop cassé l'épaule à quel
point elle ne faisait pas les faits
photo de m bales on est poli les
pantalons tellement mal ajustements
largement grand voir conforter ses parts
comme la norme puis j'avais les cheveux
longs en plus à ce moment le début des
discours des bois pour ceux qui nous
éclairent avec avec un shoot h à pobla
puisque ce qui me semble des jets
c'est sûrement instagram vous irez voir
ça c'est très bien on évalue change
maintenant j'ai que du noir dans ma
garde-robe
je pense que c'est les traumatismes gala
contre des projets en ce moment chez de
la radio et vendredi soir à 21h à
radio-canada ici première l'émission
s'appelle jusqu'au bout à ses coups de
beats toujours 10 à toute épreuve
c'est gentil mais on est vraiment sur la
musique on est vite il s'est vraiment
dès vendredi soir musicaux non juste des
nouveaux artistes locaux comme un peu
mon rêve des dernières années est-ce que
tu as encore le podcast en fait toujours
union avec alex non je dirais qu'avec la
pandémie on a été très relax sur le
podcast depuis presque la dernière année
on a dû faire deux épisodes mais chose
quoi faire sinon les vendredis même
assez une importante couche à télé
pirate soi même et les autres années moi
j'aime ça je trouve ça toujours un peu
parce que je suis pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
tendance à aimer critiqué les choses
outre un public chahboun c'est à dire
qu'il faut que tu te forger une opinion
rapidement sur un conducteur regarde le
concept de regarder via les enfants
quand t'es fait c'est ça non c'est des
émissions qui sortent le fait que ces
élites toutes les nouveautés ou à peu
près télévisuelle
qu'ils sortent dans la sexy c'est
vraiment la critique mais j'aime ce
genre se sait j'ai découvert un nathalie
petrowski que les gens c'est mon tout le
monde a une opinion sont nathalie
petrowski lé mois je l'adorais ça fait
des bonds souvent loin des tests
occupation double un gîte pour quelqu'un
qui le détestent ça m'a parlé beaucoup
d'allégations arctique a tout le temps
puis claque larmes a été investie parce
qu'avec des opinions sur les personnages
est-ce que tu déteste ça tangue sous le
thème comprendre son analyse ce que j'ai
compris des ailes puisque j'aime d'elle
c'est que six femmes qu'ils aient des
opinions tranchées rapidement mais qu'
aucune difficulté à se faire contredire
sur le moment montrent qu' à ce jour il
n'y est pas arrivé un seul moment où
j'ai fait pour vrai chez fitch a par
rapport aux suis pas d'accord puis ou
assez braquée jamais enfin je pense que
c'est bien quand on a cette expérience
de proximité le avec elle c'est sûr que
quand tu es la personne qui se fait
critiquer plutôt pour la chance de
pouvoir y répondre c'est un peu plus
difficile mais bref et non j'aime ce jeu
j'ai beaucoup plaisir c'est le fun
d'arriver dans un show qui est rodé
depuis longtemps ici leur quatorzième
saison moi j'arrive le ils savent
comment ça marche mais ça a été facile
pour moi de m'intégrer mais c'est ce gie
plus l'habitude d'être dans la
propagation de l'amour le tout à fait
radio juste des choses que j'aime je
parle aux gens que j'aime
il n'y a pas assez de temps dans une vie
je trouve qu'il faut voir c'est trop de
temps à critiquer fait que ces lattes la
sphère que je trouve le plus difficile
avec c'est juste de la tv
bien souvent quand tu le fais le tu
reçois des messages gère mal son ca pas
parce que souvent le bond qui font ce
que tu critiques ça vient de là de la
place la plupart la meilleure chose que
je peux faire appliquer on a sept
minutes pour parler d'une émission fait
souvent de l'aigle et les wings ont
tourné un peu rompu finir cette même des
fois je me dis atger pas porter toutes
les nuances que que je voudrais métier
j'essaie souvent le dire
conscient qu'il ya derrière
exemple lesquels se produit leur est pas
arrivé à la télévision de façon abouti
mais bon voici ce que j'en pense
manmohan singh mais c'est ce que cela
fasse écho québec la critique qui sont
timides ces facteurs et surtout chambley
avec qui tu travailles éventuellement
après ça moi je me dis j'essaie toujours
d'être constructif puis jamais de
détruire une production pour les faits
jamais en 100 ans
puis je me dis que je critique rock
quelque chose d'une façon dont j
accepterai pas qu'un de mes projets soit
ludique et après ça n'importe quelle
critique sur un produit dans lequel tu
as mis du coeur ça fait mal c'est sûr
que ça fait mal même s'il a plus nuancé
la plus honnête possible fait que je
suis à ma conscience mais si c'est le
rôle que j'ai dans cette émission la
paix en même temps honnêtement ça me
permet je trouve d'amener une
perspective qui est intéressante et je
suis seul sur le goût de ma génération
je suis là je pense la première personne
aura six et à faire ce show le fait que
ça me permet aussi d'en n'était certains
éléments dont ils auraient pu nous
sommes entre été spontanément mais c'est
un peu un plaisir aussi d'amener l'ex
trader joe's la semaine dernière à cnn
et houda de parler des chapelles de son
monologue d'ouverture et senna
calé à tiémé se doit de rester je
comprends moi j'ai un gros fan j'ai déjà
beaucoup
il ya des ratés un petit peu dit je
trouve nonne le dernier ou
l'avant-dernier special magie de la
musique swing et ouais je la dis que tu
as le fenway mais c'est monologue
d'ouverture le puis tu vois ça sentait
la finalité parce que entre l écueil et
comme rendu de plus je sais faire des
jeux pour dire ni radio ni voter il a
pissé mandat ce monologue l'oeil il ya
une ligne qu'il 10/10/10 peuvent pas les
choses restent en panne china afin
d'offrir à ses pieds tu sais que ça le
sale gosse sales gosses parce que si
c'est probablement un des meilleurs
publics speaker est vrai un incroyable
talent de plusieurs niveaux en pis pitié
mais ce que j'aime de chapelle c'est que
sous ses allures de foi paul et mesquins
qui parlent certains sujets et c'est la
communauté trans e distincts je pense qu
il n'empêche que ce temps audi dense
rassemblant se sont dit que son discours
mais son discours son monologue
également un trait aux enveloppes et
enfin il dit il dit souvenez-vous de
l'appétit pour la démocratie ni la peine
que vous avez ressenti bleus quatre ans
des ducasses moment les 50% sont exempts
qui ressentent la même chose que le 4
puis 10 mois puis vous c'est moi j'aime
tout le monde disait que vous haïssez
entre chacun des 15 puis c'est toujours
pareil c'est bon mois il s'est vraiment
c'est un message rassemblant pour moi
c'est ce qui est ce que j'ai mis autant
de la prise de parole de ben jones qui
était complètement autre chose
c'est-à-dire lui par les bons deux de
ses fils
la difficulté qu'ont eue les personnes
seulement à six et dans les années 30
yens ou trump heist à respirer à
survivre à cette époque lui mais à la
toute fin ce qu'ils disent et
rassemblons nous me tais tu voyais en ce
sens là dedans
ce que j'appelle le dis aussi à la toute
fin avec son punch l'action punchline
évidemment mais au bout du compte que
les deux 10es prenons nous parlant même
faisons avancer l'amérique êtes bien là
après 40 ans du monde
la foire puis l'autre qui sait pas qui
va au delà des du clan démocratique la
république et c'est s'arrêter en
républicain qui regagne et mesquer un
discours rassembleur et fait le prof on
a réglé la grande majorité du problème
c'est important c'est tout le we je
ramasse le disco disait derrière ses
terres et petits mois j'ai passé les
quatre dernières années c'est drôle je
faisais ça ce matin un blanc les quatre
dernières années
tous les matins ou presque depuis que le
daily news times existence j'écoute
l'épisode 8 èmes jeux depuis l'élection
joe biden j'ai peut-être écouté en bois
fois puis sélectionner mes épisodes
tendus par les passants monde politique
américaine
c'est comme si le soudainement une page
qui se tourne et que l'on peut prendre
un petit bréviaire sa part être anxieux
par rapport à une situation qui contrôle
un exemple que peu de serment
d'incidence directe sur nous mais qui
ont une incidence sur la le climat
mondial - littéralement et bref pour
conclure mais trouve que ce qu'ils font
avec chapelle c'est que c'est un peu qui
dans une bulle
c'est un peu qui n'a dans un cas c'est
l'écueil habitants noyau savate club à
noyon ses voisins c'est sopi qui parle
et que ses voisins et qui fait des shows
d'art dans le champ de la grotte et puis
qui sait comme rafraîchissant d'avoir
quelqu'un qui qui pot qui eût qui
comment on dire au dessus de cette
polarisation le bas ils rendent un point
dans sa carrière
c était que notre brochette de succès
sont en entrevue que c'est bon et
critiquant les domaines 10,6 après la
mort de georges claude huc arrive des
choses j'attends ce que tu faisais pipi
souvent ce pas lui qui prend le 1er
janvier pas son temps parce que
justement tout le monde saute sur
l'événement puisque la course à
kiki qui va parler libre à son terme et
qu'un qui parle fait un brin infesté
présentant médias qui parlent ils
parlent de ces pays mais vraiment il
vraiment bon j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour ce thème avec l'âge et la sagesse
et la reconnaissance du fait que le
silence est une vertu aussi un certain
moment tout à fait absolument que la
merci merci merci messieurs humain est
venu encore très intéressant mais pour
le gain serait
[Musique]